this this one is dude this is
creepy okay this is jordan peterson
at liberty university some sort of
university and he's talking with other
people
and this guy rushes the stage all right
here you go speaking
forcefully let's say or perhaps even
somewhat angrily by the end was because
not only was the freeze the white noise
generator
my name is david i'm unwell i need help
i need help i just wanted to meet you so
this guy rushed on stage and he says i
need help i just wanted to meet you
talking to jordan peterson
already weird very cult-like already but
this guy does have mental issues he has
to
i'm unwell
so now he's breaking down and cry the
guy that rushed the stage is on the
stage
breaking down and crying uh there's a
couple cops
now this is footage
so the guy's crying on the floor
and jvp could not be bothered well no
he's here now
he's standing right here oh is that him
that's him that's him
say a prayer for him now this is where
it got really weird i do not exist or
deny the uh existence of you i just
what's going on one of his words
all right stop stop
[ __ ] you i paid 300 for these yeah i'll
film what the [ __ ] i want
so the guy's on the floor crying and
then jordan peterson's on his knees like
he's some sort of messiah
and this other dude is praying for him
this is really creepy
and weird it feels [ __ ] staged in a
way
you think it stays i don't know if it
feels that way i'm not saying it is
i'm just saying this whole thing it's
it's just feels
spoopy man i don't trust these people i
don't trust any of them
this is straight out of the [ __ ]
playbook of the very predatory scumbags
that i was
sucked into when i was a kid when my mom
started going to these kind of
evangelical yeah you're just taken out
of that
i don't buy it man i could be wrong
i now but when you say stage do you
think that these evangelicals
staged it and they didn't let peterson
know you think peterson was in on it
uh because remember peterson's at their
place
that's what i'm trying to figure out
because i'm with you i hate evangelicals
i hate faith healers i hate them more
than anything
i i don't know honestly i feel like
jbp is the kind of sociopath who would
just straight up
be involved in it i wouldn't say it
would be his idea
but i think that's a lot of money he's
got a lot of money and he's got a team
of people and he's got caa
and he's got all these shady connections
and i wouldn't put it past
them to set up something like this i
don't [ __ ] buy it this whole thing
stinks this thing like honestly if this
were a movie scene i'd go this is just
so
uh paint by numbers
you know uh this huge christian college
lib oh it's a christian college called
liberty university
so jordan peterson is over him because
i think jordan peterson's a lot of
things but you would never call him
stupid
well they're saying it's liberty
university so yeah
i said there are probably a lot of
crazies there that are like
yeah you know look it could be real but
the way it was
i don't know this whole thing just
[ __ ] gives me the willies i don't
like him
it's weird that you they got in a
situation where if it's not staged this
guy ran up and he realized i can't stay
sitting here
this is gonna look bad if people are
filming i have to go and pretend i'm
helping him or helping him you know what
i mean
because that's him there i believe
honestly lord i pray that
with this moment that you would just
begin to work
in the spirit
[Music]
and then these campus cops are just
standing in word it's
university for homeschooled kids
that pretty much
[Laughter]
that is the greatest description of
liberty university i have
ever heard of my life holy [ __ ]
university for homeschooled kids
so that's that's the video um this is
really really odd the whole thing was
creepy
uh the fact that this jordan peterson
thing is becoming like a cult i don't
like this [ __ ]
you know well that's why i don't really
don't trust any of these guys
when these guys purposely try to
remain sort of nebulous and enigmatic
i don't trust people he's never really
been forthcoming
he doesn't really tell anybody anything
and i don't
trust people like that i never did so
when people started telling me what a
great [ __ ]
everything he was i'm like fine read his
books enjoy his [ __ ]
get something out of it i i don't you
know i'm not gonna hate you for it but
when you take it to that [ __ ] level
i have a problem with it